ciao a tutti i ragazzi allora questa
puntata di commento commenti è venuta
dopo una diciamo un po com'è che si dice
italiano un sondaggio ti ringrazio che
ho fatto su instagram chiesto di cosa
avreste voluto parlare e tra i vari
suggerimenti che ci sono arrivati
devo dire chapeau tutti molto molto
belli infatti è stato abbastanza
difficile per me trovare un qualcosa da
selezionare c'è stato un commento ora
non ricordo che è stato che me l'ha
mandato credo che siano state più
persone che mi hanno suggerito di
parlare di rimpianti o di rimorsi perché
non fare un video nei quali chiedervi
quale fosse il vostro rimpianto ho
rimorsi o rimorso o rimorso più grande
partiamo quindi come sempre a leggere
che cosa avete scritto su instagram ha
naturalmente non dico i nomi di chi mi
rimanda anche perché a volte potrebbero
essere delle informazioni che non so se
le persone vogliono condividere
apertamente oppure no quindi nel dubbio
sto zitto non aver detto per l'ultima
volta ti voglio bene a mio nonno morì
nella notte è purtroppo una cosa che
risuona tanto con cosa che è successa
anche a me
mia nonna materna quello che è successo
che noi sempre a nonno materno detto
scusate perché diciamo mia nonna materna
e viva la mia nonna paterna aver donato
poverina scusami nonna mia nonna paterna
grazie varie volte è stata molto male e
ogni volta si è ripresa quest'anno se
non sbaglio o l'anno scorso già vedete
quanto sono confuso riguarda questa cosa
lei è stata di nuovo male mia mamma è
scesa in sicilia perché comunque rimasta
in buoni rapporti nonostante le nano la
nostra pelle
mia mamma e mio padre lo stesso più
insieme questo freud direbbe lunga però
è scesa e ha detto guardate ragazze
cerca di prendere un aereo per andare
insomma io li ho tergiversato e non non
ce l'ho fatta ad arrivare in tempo
quindi ti capisco perfettamente è un
rimpianto io in questi casi devo dire
che la cosa importante nel film secondo
me dei rapporti che abbiamo con le
persone non è tanto il finale quanto
proprio la storia in sé e per questo per
me è ancora più difficile fare questo
discorso se nel tuo caso invece il tuo
rapporto della tua storia sono sempre
stati i livelli interessanti positivi
non è di sicuro un ultima scena che ti
può rovinare questo questo film vogliamo
utilizzare questa allegoria non aver
confessato in questi tre mesi al mio ex
di provare ancora un forte amore per lui
tecnicamente questo non è né un
rimpianto nessun rimorso però perché tu
puoi ancora agire resteranno questa cosa
degli ex perché da una parte penso che
sia possibile che determinate storie di
portino a allontanati una persona con la
quale in realtà vorresti stare in altri
casi però credo che a volte la
solitudine ci faccia filtrare
dimenticare quali erano le cose negative
che ci hanno spinto ad allontanarci una
persona e che quindi ci facciano un
pochino e rivedere le cose positive non
so bene come funzioni la tua storia
quindi non entro in questi particolari
allontanarmi dalla mia ex piuttosto che
parlarne con lei per cercare di
risolvere i problemi è questo qui
secondo me si collega un colpo fino al
discorso che sto facendo prima ossia che
a volte i rapporti finiscono in maniera
strana non sempre così chiara e definita
il mio consiglio in generale per quanto
può sembrare stupido anche perché io
sono uno dei peggiori maestri e sotto
questo punto di vista perché quando io
mi fisso su una cosa che deve finire un
qualcosa vado dritto per la mia strada
raga perdete poco tempo a ingoiare i
bocconi amari perché sennò dopo vomitate
una sacher de mer è come muso un'altra
metafora
prendete un piatto ok ho una padella
appena tirate fuori dal fuoco ancora
potete lavarla se aspettate da
aspettarsi in crosta diventa più
difficile è secondo me questo è un
pochino il discorso dei panni sporchi
che in generale
nelle relazioni vanno lavati subito
forse il fatto di non aver mai fatto il
primo passo ho 22 anni e non ho mai
avuto un ragazzo io ti capisco perché io
sono pure un altro che nella vita è
sempre stato abbastanza timido questa
secondo me è la grande paura del nobel
non mi piaci che ti distrugge ed è una
cosa che riscontro in tante persone e
tante persone che piuttosto che
affrontare subito un eventuale interesse
da parte dell'altro preferiscono
continuare a farlo lievitare levitare
levitare lievitare finché nella loro
testa si innamorano ci sono dei segnali
assurdi conosco persone che pompano
troppo facilmente anche perché poi
diventa un meccanismo automatico questi
rapporti indefiniti che si hanno con gli
altri bisogna avere un pochino più le
palle un pochino più di amore nei propri
confronti nell'accettare il no e capire
che il no non sempre è legato al fatto
che fai schifo se fallito che nessuno ti
vorranno è più nella vita ma che
semplicemente le relazioni sono fatte di
incastri nel momento in cui torricelli
un no da parte di una persona
automaticamente non solo tu non vai bene
per quella persona ma quello che sono ma
manco bene per te bisogna essere molto
più sereni davanti al fallimento perché
secondo me con gli oli che ci permette
anche quando caschiamo di rialzarci e
più velocemente bisogna un pochino
giocare di più a carte scoperte perché
per assurdo oggi in cui tutti quanti
nascondiamo il nostro gioco che gioca a
carte scoperte e veramente che ti prende
contropiede ma con molta molta serenità
in bocca al lupo e comunque sei giovane
22 anni io ho il mio primo bacio dato a
22 anni era un po quindi non essermi
fidanzata con te ti ringrazio guarda
sarebbe stato il tuo più grande rimorso
quindi filati è andata molto molto bene
quel poraccio di luigi ancora oggi un po
mi sveglio la mattina e a volte mi
sembra di vedere quel cristo aver
lasciato ginnastica artistica questa è
una cosa che compare spesso persone che
hanno mollato uno sport mollato uno
strumento io ho un rimpianto
nessun rimpianto
e stato quello di non aver continuato il
violino ero pure abbastanza bravino e
non l'ho fatto col tempo mi sono reso
conto che forse nella mia vita la mia
vita non sei riuscito a fare tante altre
cose se mi fossi tanto chiuso con lo
strumento invece lo sport per esempio io
ho fatto nuoto una vita e nel momento in
cui ho detto basta non c'è più è stata
una delle cose più belle che abbia fatto
perché fondamentalmente lo facevo per
mia madre e non c'è nulla di più noioso
non so come facciate nuotatori là fuori
che passare in due tre ore a fissa le
mattonelle del fondale le maioliche
verde acqua cioè che c'è sempre questa
grandissima inventina da parte chi le
crea mi mette un angoscia assurda senza
contare che sott'acqua da un certo punto
è cominciato a cantare cioè faccio è
sott'acqua kant e quindi dopo un'ora di
concerto mi rompe voglio essere tornata
a casa dopo una separazione di qualche
mese non è vero che le persone cambiano
in questo caso si può sempre riuscire si
chiama separazione apposta perché poi
giusto un avvocato poi andare e tornare
e poi a un certo punto poi anche non c'è
nulla di definitivo nella vita
correttissimo ti lascio anche qua sotto
il numero di lavinia solo veramente poco
di situazioni che sono delle catene
dalle quali non puoi uscire la maggior
parte delle catene volte ce li mettiamo
noi per paura di che siano figli
situazioni ma poi quello ma poi quella
mappa quello pensiamo così tanto agli
altri non pensiamo a noi pensa ci
ragiona c e fanno scelta se hai fatto
una volta riuscita a farlo anche una
seconda volta e anzi con maggiore
consapevolezza aver fatto coming out
troppo tardi non so quanti anni abbia
quanti anni abbia to iowa estro yoda ma
troppo tardi non esiste cioè finché lo
fai non è troppo tardi e anzi questa
orribile a chiunque da fuori ma non solo
per il discorso di coming out non è mai
troppo tardi per prendere una scelta per
dire io voglio fare questo o per dire io
sono questo e se la società vi fa
credere che invece il vostro posto sia
un altro secondo me è un po da prendere
con le pinze perché non esiste un vero e
proprio posto delle persone se non
quello nel quale si sentono a loro agio
quindi le etichette più delle volte
secondo me portano le persone a sentirsi
sbagliate
non ascoltare la propria pancia non
essermi goduto e bay periodi di
solitudine senza amore odio quanto ti
capisco io ho vissuto una solitudine
infinita praticamente di vent'anni e poi
da vent'anni e poi in realtà questa è
una cosa triste è che coincidono con il
momento e come sono tanto l'apparecchio
perché io mi ero detto finchè c'è un
apparecchio non voglio vedere anima viva
appena mi tolgo l'apparecchio sarò
finalmente scopa bile in realtà era una
cosa così stupida mia aspetta non
esserti co tutti i periodi di solitudine
volevi di che vole tromba giro under
isola
no no scusa
stavo facendo una parabola ok è aver
fatto una ricetta seguendo cucino è
buttata beh dipende perché se hai fatto
la carbonata francese ha avuto anche
tanto coraggio lasciare che mi hai
condizionassero le mie scelte lavorative
quando avevo vent'anni
allora allora allora quanti anni hai
adesso non può più cambiare niente
non capisco come mai nella vita veniamo
istruiti a sentirci così tanto vincolati
ormai delle nostre decisioni ci
metteremmo molto meno tempo a dire
proviamo a cambiare rotta che a
continuare a rimuginare a piangerci
addosso su quelle strano percorrendo non
averci provato con un ragazzo perché
devono essere i maschi a fare il primo
passo
disse colei che rimase single per il
resto sua vita
a parte gli scherzi è vero che per una
donna eterosessuale ad oggi c'è tanto da
mettersi i capelli in testa i capelli in
testa propria
ovviamente il sì le mani in testa però
anche vero che per gli uomini è tosta e
quindi a volte secondo me per capire un
pochino a un uomo che magari può essere
in difficoltà che te piace non c'è
niente di male e poi vedi dopo sere sarà
un cavaliere non allineato se no
ma la reciprocità e poi vieni come si
comporta perché tanto voglio dire il
primo passo non sempre è sinonimo di una
persona cioè di un uomo vero magari c'è
un po di paura magari in cui ti paura
non si comporta ancora meglio
cartellino rosso non essermi difesa da
kimi e bulli data a scuola un
grandissimo rimpianto guarda che tutti
quanti in un modo o nell'altro subiamo
un pochino di violenza più o meno grave
da parte del mondo che ci circonda
indietro non c'e poi tornare però
secondo me la cosa positiva è che quel
tipo di atteggiamento può aiutare a
sviluppare carattere forza ascolto
empatia
ecco utilizza quelle armi per combattere
adesso so che il passato può far male
per molto più facile risolvere il
passato che creare una macchina per
tornarci dietro aver dato il cuore a chi
voleva solo giocare il palleggio col
cuore si macchia di sangue e il sangue
segna la via del karma non so che cosa
ho detto semplicemente un tema che vi
invito a ripetere tutti quanti averla
data a lui e non averla data a lei
amen vai dalla chi vuoi tu aver
interrotto gli studi di giovani e
ripigliati troppo brutale e una cosa che
vorrei fare io più avanti che per me è
sempre stato di grande peso è stato
quello di non essermi laureato deve
essere rimbalzato all'università
all'altra una facoltà all'altra senza
mai quagliare ho fatto tantissime altre
cose mi rendo conto di avere delle
fortune che persone che invidio laureate
non hanno o c'è sempre tempo più avanti
quando avrò non lo so se ci arrivò a 40
50 anni 60 anni va a finire che sarò il
vecchio babbione vicino ad altre persone
che sta facendo l'università per il
piacere di sapere gli schemi che dicono
che bisogna fare tutto entro un tot di
tempo non averla fatta pagare al mio ex
da vinci ti amano aderenza esistono i
sicari non aver cominciato prima la
dieta adesso sarà un figurino si è
sempre in tempo inizia adesso e un
domani sarà un figurino non aver
iniziato alcun tipo di sport da bambina
adesso sono un bronco ciocco guarda io
ho iniziato
l'anno scorso a fare pallavolo perché mi
è sempre piaciuta e non ho mai avuto
tempo palle per farlo finché la mia
amica roma ha detto ma ti va di fare un
corso amatoriale è stata la scelta
migliore che io potessi fare in generale
e quindi cioè scegli un qualcosa e fallo
che va ebook dc poi magari va bene
magari va male un gruppo o un bronco
gioco e il nuovo hashtag commentate
bronco ciocco qua sotto se vorrete un
pochino anche voi di fortuna quest'anno
non essere stata in grado di reagire
come avrei voluto ad un momento motore
fedele tesoro mio difficilmente noi
reagiamo come vogliamo spesso leggiamo
come pochi possiamo potevamo come
possiamo quindi non è reagito come
voluto in egitto evidentemente come
potuto bisogna a volte veramente darsi
una pacca sulla spalla e dire questo è
quello che si è riuscito a fare prende
in una lezione
fanne tesoro per renderti più si mila
persone che tu vorresti essere non
ascoltare me stessa
errore sbagliatissimo essere stata
innamorata di un ragazzo sei anni senza
aver mai confessato i miei sentimenti
tesoro ti rendi conto
se tu l'avessi detto subito quanto ti
saresti tolta subito dalle palle questa
cosa qui subito sei anni
ora la bella estate nostro ora diglielo
se puoi
togliti sa spada di damocle vada come
vada
andiamo avanti in tutti i due casi la
realtà che ti capisco benissimo però
cerco di fare la [ __ ] finiamo con
l'ultimo commento non aver mandato a
quel paese più persone c'è sempre tempo
per rimediare diciamo tutti insieme
[ __ ] ragazzi grazie mille per
questi commenti fatemi sapere qua sotto
la vostra magari su qualche commento che
avete sentito se
ha risuonato in qualche modo con voi o
se magari avete dei consigli ulteriori
che potete dare che io non ho dato
fatemi sapere se vista piaciuto questo
format quali potrebbero essere altri
temi da utilizzare li vedo su instagram
ma quando si tratta di scegliere il tema
diverto anche naturalmente a leggere i
commenti che mandate qua sotto grazie
ancora per quelli che avete mandato
nello scorso video come sempre servire
se vi piace questo format commento
commenti iscrivetevi a questo canale
mettete un like aiutate a farlo
conoscere alle persone che magari a
qualcuno ma perché vi do un bacio ci
vediamo
non so quando faremo questo format ma di
base come sempre questa domenica con una
puntata di cucina buttata alle 12 ciao